what role do you believe that
xenoestrogens such as bpa phthalates and
analogues are playing in the rate of
transsexualism
given their established high occurrence
in human bodies and known effects on the
ina h3
the human sdn i don't recognize those
last two
abbreviations but the the larger
question is
basically we've got um
estrogens entering the water supply
entering the environment at rates that
are
far higher than they ever have before
from things like phytoestrogens which is
to say that estrogens
and their analogues exist in nature
but we have been synthesizing them and
then
releasing them through our trash and our
urine
uh into water supply that then
effectively feminizes boys
uh and uh absolutely that's happening
yes um you know it's it's you know how
explanatory is it
how many how many hypotheses are there
each of which have some
role to explain in the actual
legitimately increasing rates of
transsexualism
i don't know but it is certainly one
factor
yeah it's certainly one factor um
there's also clearly
a cultural contagion factor
which dovetails with a general um
general disruption of normal
environments so
sure but that's i mean i think there are
there are many
many things going on with regard to the
rise and trans and this person
specifically writes transsexualism
i think that's intentional right like
transsexualism and transgender
you know you know as i as i asked in my
recent letter to
to abigail schreier in our letter wiki
about specifically
the contagion aspect of the rise in
in teenage girls declaring themselves
transgender at what point did we stop
calling him
calling it transsexual and started
calling it transgender this is
a muddling of the issue at best and
frankly
um transgender you know acting um
in ways that is are historically more
like the other sex would act
um should warrant certainly nothing
hormonally or surgically and probably
nothing at all
um you know at least within some
confines whereas you know tran
transsexualism like actually
legitimately feeling like one of the
many
manifestations of your sex um is out of
whack with the sex um that you that you
are
you know usually it's your it's your
brain telling you for sure
that the sex that your chromosomes and
your gametes
and your anatomy and your physiology say
you are is not the thing that you say
you are
you know is are our xenoestrogens
contributing
to basically a broader array of intersex
conditions effectively yeah
i think i think they are but you know
but there's also social contagion which
may have nothing at all to do with that
but it's really a different evolution of
of transness but what i wanted to get at
was the interaction between these things
i think that there's some
gateway which looks like i feel like
something's off
right i feel like something is off and i
want it not to be off anymore
and so i'm looking for the thing that's
off so i can fix it right
yep and the point is okay one of the
things the slide will be off
is that you are getting a lot of uh
um estrogens that you're not supposed to
be exposed to
if you're uh a boy or you're not
supposed to be exposed to them if you're
anybody but if you're a boy it has a
particular effect which is making you
feel
even more off and then somebody says you
know what a lot of people who are
feeling off
are really just fine they're just facing
a kind of oppression where civilization
is telling them that they are something
it's denying who they really are and it
sounds like you know what
maybe that's it maybe i really am
something
else and i would feel fine if i was that
thing but i'm being told i'm this other
thing and that's why everything seems so
wrong and so people embrace it
and then the point is well that didn't
work because everything is still
crazy right you're still interfacing
with a world that
is not well suited to you and so and no
wonder that this
is largely happening at the point that
these kids are teenagers when guess what
you're doing as a teenager is you're
trying to figure out who you are
and why you no longer are the kid you
once were and are not yet the adult that
you might become
or are hoping to become or haven't yet
even imagined what it might look like to
become
that that age that era in your life is
exactly
about it doesn't quite feel right this
isn't fitting i'm trying to figure out
what it is that i'm going to be doing
and so to have a political ideology move
in and say we've got the solution for
you it involves going into the knife and
taking hormones that are going to
change your life forever well that's
that's child abuse
yeah it is i mean at the same moment
that you frankly
have um cardi b
telling you what uh you know the cool
sexuality is which is
insane then you have joe biden sitting
down with cardi b
for an interview because the democratic
party is of course on board
you can't make this stuff out the point
is everything is broadcasting some
message that you can't possibly process
normally because it's not a normal
message it's a malevolent message
and anyway i think what you're finding
is a lot of people looking for
the same thing that makes them
susceptible to get rich quick schemes
and snake oil right the i
the sense that there's got to be some
way there's just got to be some way tell
me
what switch i can flip and now hey guess
what we've got the ultimate switch if
you find
something off-putting about the sexual
message you're being expected to
interface with
then there's a reason for that and it's
called trans and
here's what you got to do and so anyway
the point is
the bpa and the other estrogens that you
may be taking in
feed into the sense that something isn't
right and then this other thing
doesn't have to be connected to it
directly it just has to be connected to
the fact that people
for whom things don't feel right are
looking for an answer and this answer
happens to be fashionable at the moment
which isn't to say
that there aren't real transgender
people which there are and there always
have been but
the point is the level of it the degree
to which this has
risen as an issue can just be
a matter of lots of things that create a
sense of being abilities
and a small number of solutions that are
becoming fashionable and
there you have it
[Music]
you